Here's one of the things from the quiet on the set documentary
that I found super weird.
In episode two,
we hear from child actor Kyle Sullivan,
and he tells us about the time
that he went over to Brian Peck's house for a barbecue.
He says his house was just really weird.
Apparently, there was this whole room dedicated to planet of the apes.
He was walking through it, and he noticed something that didn't belong.
It was a picture or a painting of a clown.
So Kyle notices this,
and Brian Peck is apparently really,
really excited to tell him all about the painting.
He tells him it isn't just any normal painting.
It's actually from the well known serial killer, John Wayne Gacy.
He painted it.
He sent it to Brian Peck.
In fact, Brian Peck is one of John Wayne Gacy's pen pals,
and he has tons of letters from him
that he keeps in the drawer of his bedside table.
So this guy who works with children for a living
is going back and forth with John Wayne Gacy?
I have so many questions.
Let's set aside the fact that Brian Peck
only got about 16 months in jail
for what he did,
and then was let out and was allowed to work with children again.
Let's just. Let's set that aside.
Why. Why are we letting these horrible people have pen pals?
So I looked into it,
and it turns out that John Wayne Gacy had a ton of pen pals.
It turns out that lots of serial killers have pen pals
and they draw and they make art and they write books.
These mass murderers
who made it so several people don't even get to live anymore.
They are given art supplies and pens
and allowed to have hobbies and communicate with all kinds of people.
So, again, I just have to ask, why?
If you mass murder people,
I'm sorry, you don't get to do art anymore.
You don't get to go write thousands of people and have pen pals.
It's ridiculous.
And like I said before,
if we were a serious society,
we would be serious about how we punish people who hurt children.